you have some similarities with jordan
peterson on this issue
and i know that you haven't talked much
about jordan peterson and i wanted to
know if you had any disagreements with
what he says
frankly i pay very little attention but
if you want to know about jordan
peterson i think the best thing i can
refer you to
is a article by uh nathan
robinson very sharp acute critic in his
journal
current affairs it's called something
like
the intellectual we deserve or something
like that
i think that that's basically my answer
other than that i don't pay any
attention
i mean there's some issues on which i
probably agree with hitler
no it doesn't mean much
some people have suggested that they
should that we should
remove universities that and this is
remin jordan peterson for example
said suggest students don't go to
universities anymore because of the bias
because of
the unitary point of views and this is
reminiscent of
anarchist ivan ilitch's desire to
eliminate
listen to what jordan peterson is saying
he's saying universities are dominated
by the left
now for him the left is anybody to the
left of attila the hun
in fact the universities are dominated
by the right
he's so far on the right that that looks
like the left to him
but does it make sense to tell students
not to go to universities
it's crazy it's one of the places where
you can
uh there's lots of things wrong but
there are resources and opportunities
that simply don't exist anywhere else
you can't there are opportunities to
become
a free independent creative individual
working with others uh you just don't
have elsewhere
i'm sorry i miss sorry i misspoke i
didn't mean that
to suggest that he suggested to
eliminate the universities i'm i'm more
trying to convey
the decentralizing of universities so
for example an online school
there's a lot you miss in an online
school your peers
one of the big parts of education is the
students you're with
that those kinds of interactions are
gone online and they're very important
for
uh educating oneself anybody who's been
in a
through a school or university situation
knows how
you can learn more from interaction with
your peers than
from sitting in on a lecture even
interaction with the faculty
so it's one thing to sit in a lecture
class or watch a television screen
and it's another thing to be in an
actual class where you're interacting
with other students and with the faculty
so yes there are
good things i mean i think it's good to
try to extend
the resources of a university elsewhere
but there's nothing to replace the
direct face-to-face interaction
not just when you're in class but when
you're when you're doing something else
when you're
sitting in a mcdonald's and having a
hamburger with your friends and talking
you